Google cloud shell provides you command
line access to your cloud resources
directly from your browser you can
easily manage your projects and
resources without having to install the
Google Cloud SDK or other tools on your
system with cloud shell the cloud SDK
g-cloud command line tool and other
utilities you need are always available
up-to-date and fully authenticated when
you need them
cloud shell provides command line access
to a virtual machine instance in a
terminal window that opens in the web
console in this hands-on lab you will
learn how to connect to computer
resources posted on Google cloud
platform via the web you will learn how
to use cloud shell and G cloud man we
encourage students to type the commands
themselves to help encourage learning of
the core concepts many allows to include
a code block that contains the required
commands you can easily copy and paste
the commands from the code block into
the appropriate places during the lab
when you're done with this lab you'll
know how to launch cloud shell and run
g-cloud commands all you need to work on
this lab is familiarity with standard
Linux text editors such as vim Emacs or
nano an account project and associated
resources are provided to you on quick
labs this self paced lab is part of the
quick labs quest GCP essentials
completing this quest earns you this
badge to recognize your achievement next
you will provision services with cloud
launcher
[Music]